-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
Now if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
While in Puerto Rico yesterday
touring Hurricane damage,
President Biden said
that his home state of Delaware
has a large Puerto Rican
population
and added that he was
"sort of raised
in the Puerto Rican community
at home politically."
Whoa, just take it easy, dude.
You sound like someone's grandpa
the first time
they meet a gay person.
"Hey, nice to meet ya.
You know, we had a gay fellow
in Vietnam with us.
At least, you know,
we all thought he was gay
on account of -- yeah,
doesn't matter, you know.
Nice to meet ya.
Do you fella shake hands or...?"
"Grandpa, stop talking!"
[ Laughter ]
It was reported that
Pennsylvania Senate candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz's research team
at Columbia University
killed hundreds of animals
over several decades,
including 329 dogs.
Even crazier, it was reported
in his campaign ad.
[ Laughter ]
Producers of
the Netflix series "The Crown"
have announced a casting call
for an actor between
the ages of 16 and 20
to play young Prince Harry,
and an actor between the ages of
55 and 60 to play young William.
[ Laughter ]
A former girlfriend of
Republican Senate --
Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
claimed in a new interview
that Walker paid for her
to get an abortion in 2009.
And the only way that will
hurt him with Republicans
is if some of that money went
to pay down her student loans.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
I don't know. I'm going to stand
by that one.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
visited a Waffle House
restaurant over the weekend
and served food to linemen
working to restore power
in the aftermath
of Hurricane Ian.
"Thanks for everything you do,"
said DeSantis
to his photographer.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump filed a
defamation lawsuit yesterday
against CNN and claimed
that the network has made
a "persistent association
between Trump and Adolf Hitler."
Yeah. Come on, CNN.
Can't a guy
hold a series of racist rallies
in a country
suffering skyrocketing inflation
without being
compared to Hitler?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Peloton. Peloton news.
Peloton announced
a new partnership with Hilton
yesterday
to put exercise bikes
in more than 5,400 hotels
across the country.
Not to be outdone,
Days Inn announced towels.
[ Laughter ]
In a recent interview,
country singer Shania Twain
said that
she wants to collaborate with
Harry Styles in the future.
"Hey, so do we,"
said the rest of One Direction.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced that
the world's largest
indoor go-kart track
will open in New Jersey
later this year,
will include four passing lanes.
But since it's in Jersey,
there will always be
a kid in the left lane
going 15 miles per hour.
[ Laughter ]
We have one writer
who lives in Secaucus.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna do what we always
do -- take his word for it.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, rapper Snoop Dogg
announced yesterday
he will release
a cannabis-infused
onion ring snack
called Snazzle Os.
So, if you like marijuana
and you like onion rings,
you don't say.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!